Hi, everybody.
As [INAUDIBLE] said,
I'm Michael Silliski.
I'm a product management
director here on Google Play,
and I'd like to kick
off the day by sharing
a few thoughts with you
about the state of Play,
and the amazing momentum that
we've been seeing with Android,
with Play, and with you guys--
the app developers-- recently.
I'd also like to highlight a
few key trends that I think
we've really been
focused and are
really relevant to
you guys, and then
point out a few things I think
you'll see throughout the day.
So let's get started.
As I think you guys
all know, Android
has become an incredibly
popular platform.
And as somebody who's been
at Google since we launched
the G1 back in 2008, it's
incredible to see over
just six short years how
we've gone from a few thousand
devices to now
Android accounting
for three out of every four
smartphones in the world.
More recently, we've
seen amazing momentum
on tablets with
Android now counting
for three out of every five
tablets in use in the world.
And Android's not just popular.
It's also become
increasingly powerful.
At this point,
over 85% of devices
are running Android
4.0 or above.
But as you guys know,
the Android opportunity
is not just about market share.
It's about the
aggregate impact, and we
crossed an amazing
milestone this year.
We now have over one billion
active Android devices
in the world.
A number that I find
just staggering.
And that growth has continued to
increase in velocity over time,
and it's projected to
continue into the future.
Taking a regional
view here at Europe,
the Middle East, in
Africa-- EMEA forecasts
are for smartphone sales
to double over five years.
As you can see, Android
is the blue on the top.
And so Android's capturing
the vast majority
of those increased
sales going forward,
and the same is true for tablets
with tablet sales continuing
to increase and Android
capturing the lion's share.
But as you guys know, the
Android platform story
is not a regional story.
Android has really become
a truly global platform.
We now have 60
device manufacturers
selling Android devices
all over the world.
We have partnerships with
329 mobile operators,
and they're distributing
devices in over 190
different countries.
And I think that's one
of the first themes
that I wanted to talk
to you guys about, which
is the increased
internationalization
of Android.
And particularly
a focus that we've
had recently both on
Android and on Play
around emerging markets.
Despite all of that
growth, only one
out of four people in the
world today have a smartphone.
And we at Google
are focused on how
we can bring the next five
billion people online.
And one key effort to
do that is Android One.
Android One's an effort to
bring high quality devices
to emerging markets,
like India, Indonesia--
like the Philippines
and South Asia.
And with Android
One, we're trying
to make devices that
have fast processors,
smooth interactions,
and we've actually
partnered with device
manufacturers and silicon chip
makers to create
reference designs
to allow these to not only
be high quality devices-- not
only powerful devices, but
also affordable devices.
And devices that
have features that
are particularly relevant
in the local markets.
For example, in
India-- FM radios.
They're not only high quality
and affordable devices,
but they're also
devices that will always
run the latest
version of Android,
which you guys
know is important.
Here on Play, we build
the distribution layer
and the commerce layer
on top of Android.
And so, the Android
platform expansion
into emerging markets through
Android One and other efforts
is a tremendous
opportunity for us.
And we have really been
prioritizing making sure
that users and all those
different countries can pay.
Whether it's your paid apps,
whether it's in-app billing,
whether it's
subscriptions-- we want
to make sure that
all of those people
have a seamless and [INAUDIBLE]
way to engage with your apps
and services.
And so we spent a ton of time
over the past couple of years
making sure that all these
markets are payments enabled.
Earlier this year
we launched Paypal,
and we have Paypal live
in 12 different markets.
Another way to pay
in a wide region.
We've seen increased popularity
of direct carrier billing,
and we've been focused on
expanding that internationally
as well.
We now have direct
carrier billing
in over 25 different markets,
and that covers about half
of the Android user base.
We've also been
working really hard
to get our gift cards
program rolled out
in as many markets as possible.
And in under two
years, we're now
at 18 different markets
with gift cards.
And I'm really happy to be able
to say that all of that work
seems to be paying
off for developers.
We've paid out over $5
billion to developers
through Google Play.
It's become a really
big opportunity,
and it continues to
grow year over year.
We paid out more than
2 and 1/2 times as much
last year as we did
the year before,
and we're looking forward to
increased growth in the future.
So looking forward
a little bit, we're
around the corner from
the Android L release.
And I wanted to highlight
a couple of trends
with L that I think
are particularly
relevant to you guys.
One is material design.
So with material design,
we challenged ourselves
to come up with a new
visual look for Android that
would synthesize the classic
principles of good design
with the possibilities
that technology affords us.
And so material design
brings a new look and feel,
new principles of motion, and
better animation to Android.
It is really beautiful.
It's a joy to use.
I think you guys
will really like it.
And I think now is a great
time-- with the L preview
out there-- to go
look at how you
can bring material
design into your apps.
Another major trend of
L is expanding Android--
as [INAUDIBLE] said--
from phones and tablets
into a new wave of
device types, and I
think we're just on
the brink of this.
TVs, and wearables, and auto.
So with Android TV,
we're bringing Android
into the living room with
big screen apps, and games,
and content.
And not just a streaming
service, but also
platform on which you can
build incredibly rich,
visually stunning games.
And we think it's something
that has mass market
potential with a
variety of form factors
and multiple manufacturers.
And best of all
for you guys, it's
less work because it's a
simple incremental expansion
pure Android app.
Second platform I
wanted to mention
is Android Wear, which brings
Android onto your watch.
With devices like
this Moto 360 which
went on sale just this week.
This is a really
beautiful device.
There's a range of
devices out there now.
And I can tell you
that it's really
transformed the way that I
interact with apps and services
that I've used over
a period of years.
Which I think for
every app developer
is an opportunity to think about
how you can bring your apps
and services onto the wrist.
So Android Wear organizes
your information.
It surfaces to you without
you even having to ask,
and so whether it's
messaging, or appointments,
or weather notifications--
who knows what in the future.
But I hope you
guys will dream up
the use cases that make
this a medical device.
And then lastly,
Android Auto, which
brings Android into the car.
Android Auto was designed
with safety in mind
with a simple and
intuitive interface.
With integrated
steering wheel control.
With integrated voice control.
And you can connect
your phone to get
your contacts and your messages
and your music all on the car
without having to take
your eyes off the road.
And I'm really
excited about this.
Particularly with over two
dozen auto industry partners.
So I think as we look
from this transition
from phones and tablets to
TV, and wearables, and auto,
this big opportunity both
for us and for you guys.
Because Android and Play
provide the platform,
but you guys are
going to provide
the apps and the
services that actually
make these devices
useful and worthwhile.
So an expansion of types
of apps that you can build.
A new design language.
A new range of devices.
New markets around the world.
So how do you take
advantage of it?
So we're going to talk about
that throughout the day,
but I wanted to kick
off by highlighting
five key points there are things
that we think about ourselves
every day as we're
building apps.
And I think you guys want
to think about as well.
So first as I mentioned, get
ready for L platform release.
L is one of the biggest
releases we've ever done.
It not only brings
a new UI paradigm.
It brings a new runtime,
enhancer notifications,
and over 5,000 APIs which means
new capabilities for you guys.
Things that you can
use to build new types
of apps that haven't
existed before.
Second, capitalize on these
new device opportunities.
We're on the verge of
the next wave of devices,
and right now is a
time when it's really
a Greenfield opportunity.
The L preview
release is out there,
and so it's a
great time to start
thinking about how you can
define what a device like this,
or what having the Android
platform on your tablet,
your wrist, and your TV means.
What kind of services
can exist over
the next few years that
don't exists today.
Third, it's a great
time to go global.
There's over a billion devices
in use around the world,
and whether we're sitting
in California or in London
or in Tokyo, our
users are everywhere.
And as we work to bring those
next five billion devices
online with efforts
like Android One,
I think you're going
to see that it's only
going to become
more international.
And so the opportunity
is there to think
about the local unique
needs of your users
whether they're in India,
or Brazil, or Indonesia.
Fourth, if you're
building games,
integrate Google
Play Games services.
Google Play Games services
has grown in a short time
to become the fastest
growing mobile game
network of all time.
We've added over 100 million
new users in the last six months
alone.
So it's an opportunity
to get a lot
of the features and
the infrastructure
that you would otherwise
have to build for yourself,
and it's an
opportunity to increase
your visibility both through the
Games network and to the store.
And we hear consistently
from developers
that integrating Games
services and using features
like achievements, leaderboards,
quests, gifts, multiplayer.
The whole range of services
helps them increase engagement
with their users, retain
their users for longer,
and extend the
life of their game.
And fifth, critical
for us and for you
guys-- our relentless
focus on quality.
You guys know your users.
You know that quality
is important for them.
It also really impacts how
well your apps monetize.
So for every additional star you
get in your rating in the Play
Store, we see a
multiplier effect
on revenues to developers.
So I encourage you to
maximize your marketing money,
and make sure that you're
engaging and retaining
those users.
And so finally, I
just want to mention
that Google's here to help.
Throughout the whole
life cycle, we really
honestly spend all
of our time every day
thinking about
how we can improve
the tools and the services that
we make available to you guys,
and how we can make your lives
better as app developers.
Whether it's in the store,
whether it's making payments
easier for users, whether
it's making devices
available in more places to
more different types of users.
Whether it's building out the
developer console providing
tools like A/B testing to you,
this is what we do every day.
And so I'm really looking
forward to meeting as many
of you as possible,
hearing your feedback,
hearing your questions, hearing
your ideas, and thank you.